Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Tonight, Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made
billionaire investor,
Chris Sacca joins the Tank.
The GeoOrbital wheel is
a step into the future.
That is not worth
millions of dollars.
Oh, my God!
Where's the brake?
So, I don't like your deal,
and here's why.
So, are you
rejecting her offer?
If I'm gonna do something
powerful in this life,
I need to do things
that matter.
Own your journey.
Own what you've learned.
I just don't think
you're an entrepreneur.
I'm absolutely gritty
and driven, so...
Mark, give her a number!
Shut up, Kevin.
Honig: What are you gonna do
with your hands
when you're
standing there?
Deutsch: You're going
like this?
I'll probably put them
in my pockets.
You can't do
in your pockets.
‐Yeah, you can.
‐Don't do pockets.
‐Like this.
‐No, no.
Whatever you do.
Side ‐‐ Do side.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an innovation
in personal transportation.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Isaac Deutsch.
And I'm Zoli Honig.
And we're the founders
of WaiveCar.
We're here today asking
for $500,000
in exchange for 2%
of our company.
WaiveCar's the world's
first all‐electric
and free
car‐sharing service.
WaiveCar allows its users
to use our 100% electric cars
completely for free
for two hours at a time.
Now, before we get too far,
I know you're thinking it ‐‐
"How the heck are these guys
making money?"
Well,
the answer is advertising.
To put it simply,
companies pay us to display ads,
and our customers contribute
by driving those ads around.
Each of our cars is equipped
with a vinyl advertising wrap,
as well as a military‐grade,
dual‐sided LCD display
that can display
dynamic ad content.
This means we can show ads
based on time, GPS location,
or really any other factors
that we choose.
Signing up to drive
with WaiveCar is really easy.
Just download our app,
sign in,
and you'll see all
of the available WaiveCars
on the map.
Just choose the one
that's closest to you,
and hit "reserve."
You know have an electric car
for free.
We launched in Los Angeles
five months ago
and have seen
tremendous growth.
Our problem now is,
we need more cars.
We would love to have
one of you Sharks join us
to rapidly expand our company
across the world.
This is WaiveCar,
the wave of the future.
Both: We waive the fee,
you drive for free.
You know, I'm amazed you said
"five months ago,"
because I have actually seen
WaiveCars in Santa Monica.
Yeah, our home base
is in Santa Monica.
We have 20 vehicles
driving around.
‐So that's pretty fast.
‐What happens after two hours?
Does it eject me
out of the driver's seat?
$5.99 an hour
after that.
Corcoran: Do you return it
to the same place
you picked it up?
No, so, right now,
you have to return it
in the city of Santa Monica.
Anywhere?
Any public meter.
Electric cars, you're
allowed to park
at any public meter
for free.
Yeah.
So, every time
you start a booking,
we require the users to do
a quick check
that the car's clean,
that there's no body damage...
What's your break‐even
per car?
Well, so,
the cost of the car itself
is about $1,000 a month
with insurance and everything.
Our break‐even will be
about $1,500.
Over that is profit.
We actually have done
zero dollars in marketing,
and we have 4,300 users
just in our
first five months.
Wow!
Look, it's got to be
capitally intensive, right?
So,
how much have you raised?
We raised $1.3 million.
When would you expect
to make a profit?
So, it really depends on the
amount of cars we have, right?
If we're selling out
our 20 cars right now
at $5,000 per car,
we'd be making about
$1.2 million in revenue.
We'd be walking away
with about $300,000 in profit.
Now,
those aren't great margins.
Once we move to 200 cars,
we'd be doing
$12 million in revenue,
so we'd be walking away
with $800,000‐and‐change profit.
Do you have guys have
some unfair advantage?
Are you better at something
than everybody else?
So, the screen
that we have on our cars,
a lot of people
kind of overlook.
"Oh, it's a screen.
Whatever."
This is actually
crazy custom‐engineered
for this vehicle.
You can't slap this
on any other vehicle.
It has to be
safety‐ and crash‐tested,
and the manufacturer
that has this
has over 200 patents
on the display.
And we have an
exclusive agreement with them.
Guys, look,
I like the idea.
I think you guys have
a chance at success.
But the challenge
for me is,
the variability of advertising
is crazy.
You know, it's hard for
traditional media companies
to sell advertising.
There's video boards
that are popping up
on top of hot‐dog stands
in New York, right?
Yeah.
They're everywhere.
The inventory
is being saturated,
which hurts your rate.
The more you spend,
the more you need.
And, you know, that's gotten
a lot of industries in trouble.
And so for those reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
My concern is,
how do you stop Uber
or anybody else
from putting signage ‐‐
wrapping their cars?
You talked about that
that's a proprietary sign,
but I'm sure that somebody
can figure out
another kind of sign
to put on top of a car.
I'm concerned that other people
can take your model,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
How many advertisers
do you have?
So, we're only
five months old,
so we really haven't
even started
the sales process
of building...
Do you have
any advertisers?
So, we have
Oscar Health Insurance.
Are they the only guys
you've got so far?
No, we have
another advertiser ‐‐ uh, XYZ.
You guys are
really embryonic.
I like the idea, but, boy,
there's just no track record.
Sacca: Guys, you're
in the advertising business,
but so far,
you have two advertisers.
You don't really
have any proprietary tech.
You're an integrator
that doesn't really control
any leg of the stool here.
More companies have raised
more billions of dollars
in this space
than ever before ‐‐
Uber and Lyft in terms
of ride sharing.
But the
number‐one challenge
those services are encountering
right now
is finding more drivers
and more cars.
And that's exactly
the problem.
That's exactly the problem.
That's why we're doing this.
Right now ‐‐
So, for Uber ‐‐
What's Uber's biggest ‐‐
What you're doing is,
you're doing their R&D for them.
But what's
Uber's biggest problem?
You're figuring it out.
You right now are running
this incredible experiment.
And Uber's watching you,
and they're saying,
"Hey, is this thing
gonna work?"
But let me ask you
a question.
Why doesn't Uber advertise
right now?
Because they're gonna let you
blow all the money
and figure out
if it works or not.
[ Laughs ]
You really think so?
Or they'll ‐‐
Or they'll allow us
to ‐‐ to give their drivers
free cars.
That's what we would
love to do.
Uber has an ad sales force
right now
that's bigger
than your company.
You're right.
Uber has a fleet that's
much bigger than your company.
But you like to get in early.
That's your shtick.
And they didn't pay any money
for those cars.
They don't own any of them.
We'll own them.
You guys ‐‐
They don't have to own them.
[ Chuckles ] See, that's ‐‐
That's why there's one company
that's worth $63 billion
and another one that's not,
right?
No,
but we're a third party.
I've yet to hear you say
you're bringing anything
to the party...
We're a third party.
...that you do better than
anything else on the planet
other than attach that
to that.
And we have
the ability to ‐‐
And that is not
worth millions of dollars.
I don't think there's any way
you guys survive this,
because I have yet to see
anything you do better
than anybody else
on the planet.
At the end of the day,
I'm canceling the ride.
I'm out.
O'Leary: Let me
make you an offer, okay?
I think you've already heard
what Sacca says ‐‐
that you have nothing
that anybody else
can't just emulate
and crush you
after you've proven
that it works.
That's a concern
for any investor.
Secondly, I know a lot
about the advertising business
because I spend
a lot in it.
I'm the financial service
industry.
I'm buying ads off everybody
all the time.
I don't know
if this is gonna work or not.
So, that's another risk.
The only way I would
do this deal is this way.
I will loan you $500,000
at 12%.
It's a 36‐month loan,
number one.
Number two,
I want 4% of your equity
just for that loan.
In addition to that,
I want any unsold
digital advertising.
That's the only way
I would do this deal,
given I've got two huge risks.
Well, what are you gonna
pay us for those unused,
unsold slots?
Nothing. It's unused.
So, you want the free
advertising here.
So you want 4%
of the company ‐‐
It's your rem‐‐
it's remnant inventory.
It's remnant.
You don't have ‐‐
But the remnant inventory
right now,
and we're gonna make money
from that...
If ‐‐ If it gets sold
for anything,
then I don't get it, okay?
Why don't
you counter him?
Look, that's ‐‐
that's what I'm willing to do.
Before you counter him,
I'm gonna make you
a different deal.
♪♪
$500,000 ‐‐
no contingencies.
No interest rate,
no fancy loans.
But I want 10% of your business,
outright ‐‐
just 10%.
Two offers.
Nice, clean,
easy percent.
Well, um...
I appreciate both of the offers.
Thank you so much,
for both of you.
Kevin, um, you're basically
asking for a loan...
We don't need a loan.
Look, look ‐‐
the way I look at this,
the risk is horrendous
in your deal, okay?
Barbara,
I think a $5 million valuation,
and it's just ‐‐
it's really tough for us,
because our first ‐‐
our first round
was at $8 million
post‐money.
So, are you
rejecting her offer?
I'm not rejecting it.
I'm saying,
let's find a middle ground,
because we came in at 25,
she's at 5.
so we just need to meet
somewhere in the middle.
You know, here's the rub.
Why don't you guys counter,
then?
Do you mind, Lori?
I don't need a broker
right here.
I ‐‐ Barb, you need ‐‐
you need something to happen.
I appreciate it.
Go, just go. Just go.
‐She's a big girl.
‐Come on, come on, come on.
I'm just saying to you that,
if I had less than 10%,
I wouldn't be excited
about your business,
and that's the truth.
And yet, I totally believe
in the two of you,
so it's a simple deal ‐‐
10% for $500,000.
Okay, guys,
what are you gonna do?
Um, so, Barbara,
I think valuing us at $5 million
would be really hard.
We could do $500,000
for 5% of the company.
You know, Zoli,
you have two advertisers only.
That's it.
You haven't even proven
the concept of the business yet.
I could not negotiate
off the 10%, period.
And I think
it's a fair value.
All right,
she has not flexibility.
Do you have anything to say
regarding my deal?
Yeah, so, um...
[ Laughs ]
So, well, it's ‐‐ we would love
to have you on board,
and we think you can add a
tremendous amount of experience
for us.
Especially
on the financing side.
‐Of course I can.
‐That's what you do.
‐Yep.
So, I think the equity ask
is a little high.
Instead of 4%,
we were thinking more
like 1% for that.
and on the ad sales side,
we wouldn't necessarily give it
to you for free,
but we would give it
at an 80% discount.
80% is interesting,
but that's not really
what this deal's about
at this point.
Now, I asked for 4% equity.
You offered me 1%.
I'll meet you in the middle.
2.5, done.
2%, done.
2.25%.
2%.
[ Laughter ]
Done.
Wow.
Barbara, we love you.
I'm sorry.
I don't think
you love me enough.
Yeah, that was great.
Thanks so much.
Nice meeting you.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
O'Leary: I like them.
Greiner:
Good deal, Kevin.
Honig: When you walk
into the Tank,
you're gonna get a lot
of criticism.
I know this company
is gonna be huge,
and I'm gonna do
whatever it takes
to make it huge.
And if you don't have
that kind
of blood, sweat, and tears
going into your business,
then entrepreneurship
is not for you.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a convenient way
to keep your kids
occupied and enriched.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I am Desiree Vargas Wrigley.
And I am CEO and founder
of Pearachute,
and I'm here today asking
for $500,000
in exchange
for 6% of our company.
Sharks, our company is
gonna change the way that
parents and children discover,
share, learn, and play.
See, as parents of kids under 5,
we have a dilemma.
We want to introduce our kids
to things that they're going
to love,
like soccer, art,
swimming, music.
So we sign them up
for 12 sessions of art,
but by the third visit,
your 2‐year‐old is
in the corner crying or refusing
to get into the water,
and you still have
nine sessions left
that you cannot get refunded.
Millions is wasted
on unattended classes
because of things like
changing nap schedules
and surprise visits
from Grandma.
This is why we created
Pearachute.
Pearachute is
a monthly‐membership club
that makes it easy
for parents and caregivers
to discover, book, and drop
into the best kids' activities
in your city.
Let me show you how it works.
So, parents come to
the Pearachute kids' website,
and they can immediately
begin searching
from thousands of classes
all over the city.
They can also filter
by age and interests.
They simply select a class,
click "drop in,"
decide which child will attend,
and they're all set.
It's that simple,
all from your phone.
And because we're parents,
we know that things come up,
so we let people cancel up
to one hour before
without a penalty.
And our partners love us because
we fill classes,
and we bring revenue.
So, Sharks, who's ready to drop
into the best new business
to inspire curious
and courageous kids?
What does it cost
to subscribe?
We initially launched
126 days ago
with two plans ‐‐
a five‐pack and an unlimited.
And we launched
the five‐pack at $79
and unlimited at $99.
So, you say
you're only 126 days old.
Yeah, we're young.
Okay, so,
then give us some history
and tell us what
you've accomplished so far.
Yeah, so, I am a parent
of two little boys.
I have a 4 1/2‐year‐old
and a 2‐year‐old.
And then, I'm also a stepmom
to a 10 1/2‐year‐old.
So, I found that
when we had Griffin and Aiden
that I would sign them up
for classes.
And Griffin we signed up
for soccer at first,
but then, after a few sessions,
he just got sick of it.
He was playing
on the bouncy things.
He just wasn't going.
So, I realized there
that there was a problem.
And then we also ‐‐
I mean, I can do everything
else from my phone.
So, that was really
the desire.
And I have done this before.
This is not my first business.
Greiner: What was
your first business?
My first company is a company
called GiveForward,
and it was one of the first
crowdfunding sites in the world.
I took that company
to $5 million a year in revenue
and raised about $6 million.
That's great.
And what happened to it?
It's still going.
Do you still own equity
in it?
I do.
Are you involved
in managing it?
I'm not involved
in managing the business.
So, is it...
I'm exclusively on Pearachute
right now.
But it's not growing anymore,
is it?
It's actually doing
really well,
and it's pivoted
into a new market because ‐‐
you know what I learned
from the experience there,
which honestly, I think,
a benefit to you all,
is that I spent eight years
learning on someone else's dime
what I can now accelerate
into this business.
I want to know,
did you get whacked?
I ‐‐ The truth is that
I watched a competitor
just blow past us,
and I realized
that the founder vision
that I brought only took ‐‐
had so much value at that point,
and it was time for me
to exit the business.
So, I found a CEO that was
a great operator
and brought him in,
and I handed over
a very healthy business.
Good for you.
Thank you.
‐I know it's only 126 days...
‐Yes.
...but how much money
have you made?
So, to date,
we've made just under $50,000
in 126 days and ‐‐
And how many subscribers
do you have?
We have over 600.
What was your revenue
last month?
The ‐‐ In the last four weeks,
it's been $20,000.
Tell me how your software
interacts
with all these
different classrooms.
How do you know
about their inventory ‐‐
what classes are available
and what's not available?
So we launched
with 30 partners.
We created a very light portal
for them
that's actually
mobile‐friendly
so their instructors,
when they're on a soccer field
or in front
of a swimming pool,
can check kids in
and adjust inventory real‐time.
So, they can say,
"Four people canceled
for our art class today.
Let's put four more spots
on Pearachute today."
O'Leary:
What cities are you in?
We're only in Chicago right now,
so...
That's it?
When you look
at what this is
in terms of a vision
for this business,
there is 75 million Millennials
right now
that are going to have
another 75 million children...
I agree. I agree.
...over the next 20 years.
80% of them care more
about experiences
than they do about things.
But tell me how
you're gonna expand it.
I get it. I get it.
How 'bout New York?
No, so the demand is...
How 'bout Dallas?
How 'bout Miami?
What's happening in ‐‐
Yeah, so,
Dallas is actually next.
We've already gone out...
But how do you do that?
How do you do that?
So ‐‐
How do you do it
before somebody else does it?
So, Dallas ‐‐
what we're so excited about is
the fact that there's
a really high concentration
of kids' activities centers
in North Dallas.
But what's missing,
and I'm still waiting for it,
and you better
get to it because
why are you going
to own this space?
What ‐‐
What are you going to do
to create
the number one platform?
Why are you gonna be the winner
at the end of the day?
Why are you gonna grow?
We do plan to take
a similar model
that we took to Chicago
and put it in
the next big cities
that we think are
a great opportunity.
I asked you to tell me
how I pour gasoline
in the form of my money
onto your fire
to expand this business.
I want to know what the path is
to get every other city,
and you never answered me.
I asked you to tell me
how I pour gasoline
in the form of my money
onto your fire
to expand this business.
I want to know what the path is
to get every other city,
and you never answered me.
So, the...
That's a huge fail on your part.
I'm sorry.
I really ‐‐ I really think that
when you have the opportunity ‐‐
I'm sorry if
I didn't give you ‐‐
And you speak very quickly.
Let me finish, okay?
[ Laughs ]
All right?
‐Yeah.
I'm out.
Sacca: Is there something
you're better at
than everybody else?
I think my differentiator
is, honestly,
losing to a competitor
in my last business.
Watching some‐‐
That's it?
Watching someone else
accelerate past me
and realizing all the missteps
I'd made over eight years
when I could've done it
so much faster,
so much more aggressively.,
Do you mind if I review
that history a minute?
'Cause I feel like I'm not
quite sure I got it.
Sure.
I'm gonna tell you what I've
been hearing here.
Okay.
You started StepForward.
GiveForward.
But when the going got tough,
you exited.
That's not what I heard.
Whoa, whoa. I'm just ‐‐
you can correct me.
I just want to recite
the history.
Yeah, no, that's fair.
You know what
really concerns me?
It concerns me
what you said earlier,
when you said,
"The best part is
that I learned
on someone else's money."
I feel like you are probably
a phenomenal facilitator.
I just don't think
you're an entrepreneur.
I don't see you
as a killer.
I have never heard that before,
and I have to tell you.
You have to show me ‐‐
Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe some of my life history
will help shed some light
on how I am absolutely gritty
and driven.
So, I was born
in Costa Rica.
I grew up with a single mom
who didn't go to college,
and she said, "Your life is
only gonna be different
if you work your butt off,"
and so, that's what I did.
And I worked my butt off
to get a scholarship
to a private school,
and I ‐‐
Sorry.
[ Chuckles, clears throat ]
This is important ‐‐
tell us.
I wasn't expecting this to be
the challenge, sorry.
I went to Yale,
and I worked my butt off there.
And I realized at Yale
that it wasn't enough
to go to be a lawyer
or an investment banker.
I ‐‐ If I'm gonna do something
powerful in this life,
I need to do things
that matter.
GiveForward
wasn't just like a,
"Oh, wouldn't it be nice
if this exists?"
It was, there is a pain point,
and there's a desire for people
to give individually to people,
and that does not exist.
And I‐I beat down so many doors
with this idea,
and I fought as hard as I could
to make it go well.
But at the end of the day,
I thought,
"Maybe someone else can do this
better than I can."
But there's a point always
along the way
in building a business
where the chips are down,
nothing's going right,
and it's so tempting
to switch horses.
I think
there's going to be
a learning curve
on this business, as well,
and I don't want you learning
on my dime.
I'm out.
I like the idea.
But, to me,
my concern here is
I feel like you're biting off
a little bit more
than you're gonna be able
to chew.
I would say, get this
grounded better in Chicago.
Then, set your sights
moving on to Dallas.
I wish you the best.
I'm out.
Hey, Desiree, you know,
I, in the spring of 2000,
lost every dime I had
plus $2.125 million more,
leaving me completely
in the hole with no assets.
I was picking up spare work
off of Craigslist
to try and make rent
so I could stay in the game.
And it took me more than
a decade to get up the courage
to talk about that setback
along the way.
I was listening to you
tell your story
about being born
to a single mother in Costa Rica
and how you fought your way up
through the system to Yale,
et cetera.
Your whole demeanor changed
as an entrepreneur.
You found
a confidence in that.
Instead of coming out here
and asking for money,
I saw this whole shift
where you were giving the Sharks
an opportunity to invest
in your business.
Keep that in mind.
Own your journey ‐‐
own what you've learned
and why it makes you
so much more powerful
and why it's equipped you
to be unfairly advantaged
in this business
to win it.
If you search hard enough
in California on any given day,
you're gonna see me
in a Music Together class
with my three kids
under 5.
I will be there
singing full‐voice,
playing a recorder,
banging on a wood block.
This is my life.
I do this.
But this is
a hard product.
You're building
a two‐sided marketplace
where there has to be
enough demand on the user side
and enough supply
on the other side.
And the reality for me is
if I'm not jumping in,
I'm jumping out.
These deals for me,
I have to have my whole gut in,
or I'm out.
And so,
I hope you prove me wrong,
but on this one,
I'm out.
Okay,
thank you for the opportunity.
You have one Shark left,
Desiree ‐‐ Mark Cuban.
And he's got more billions
than that guy,
so you're lucky.
And you'll have experience,
and we're coming
to your hometown.
The big question...
is equity.
Yeah.
But to make it work ‐‐
I'm not gonna have...
I mean, let's get
that number on the table.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Mark, give her a number!
Shut up, Kevin.
I'm gonna ask for 20%
of the company.
But with the 20%,
then I can go to work for you.
You're gonna be counting on me.
‐Yeah.
I'm gonna give you
office space in Dallas.
I'm gonna have
a foundation of people
for you to work with that'll
accelerate you even more.
Okay.
Considering the traction there
that you have,
the tech
they've already built,
I actually think
that might make sense for you.
Oh, well,
he's really anxious to hear
that you think his deal
makes sense.
Aren't you, Mark?
Yep.
There's one tech investor
up here on the panel, and...
[ Laughs ]
Just one, right, Chris?
Uh‐huh. I just want to coach you
through this one a little bit,
let you know
how you're doing.
I appreciate that.
What are you gonna do?
I absolutely want
to get there with you,
and I'm wondering if
you'd be willing to come up
just a little bit
on the valuation.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll give you $500,000
for 15%.
♪♪
That is so fantastic.
I thank you so much.
I accept.
Deal.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you so much.
Congrats.
We'll do great together.
It'll be amazing.
‐Congratulations.
‐Good luck. Congrats.
Thank you ‐‐ Thank you
for the opportunity.
It was tremendous.
I was forced to acknowledge
some other things from my past
in a way that was
really positive
and actually
strengthened me,
and I appreciate
all of the Sharks
for giving me the feedback
that they did.
But I, of course,
am most excited
about the fact that today,
Mark made a deal with us,
and he's just gonna
accelerate this business
beyond anything
that we ever dreamed.
Narrator: In Season 7,
David Weiss and Ann Crady Weiss
made a deal with Chris Sacca
for their smart changing pad,
Hatch Baby.
This is a $300 scale.
I just don't buy into this
$300 changing table.
I love to get in early
in companies.
I'll do the 250K.
Yes!
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Ann: As soon as we did
our deal with Chris,
we sent him
a smart changing pad,
and he used it
with his newborn.
He gave us
incredible feedback,
not only about the setup process
but also about price point.
We re‐evaluated it
and invested heavily
in building a $99 product
that we believe will be
in every new parent's home.
We need the weight
to be as accurate as possible.
David:
Taking the price point down
was really difficult.
We took the screen out
and allowed parents to use
their phone.
We've made the size smaller
and more ergonomic
so we can save
on materials.
This isn't just
a more affordable product.
This is
an upgraded product.
Hey, guys!
What's going on?
Hey!
So, when I invest in a company,
I roll up my sleeves,
and I get involved
with the founders.
Ann and Dave
are not only open to feedback,
but they incorporate it back
into the product.
And the results are clear.
You've brought down
the price.
You've made it easier to clean
and easier to use.
Yep.
The new changing pad is
a no‐brainer.
It's a great price point,
and it gives the parents
so much comfort.
These things are gonna fly
off the shelves.
I want to see this as
a billion‐dollar company.
Ann: When we came on
"Shark Tank,"
we had never sold
an actual product.
In the year since
"Shark Tank,"
we've sold $1 million
in smart changing pads.
Let's go meet
the rest of the team.
Let's do it.
Sacca: Ann and Dave embody
the American Dream.
They saw a need
that wasn't being met.
They left their cushy jobs
and rolled the dice
on something
they believed in deeply.
And look where it is.
The sky's the limit.
Billion‐dollar outcome,
here we come.
Magazine covers to follow ‐‐
stay tuned.
1, 2, 3.
All: Hatch Baby!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a modern re‐invention
of the wheel.
Hello, Sharks.
My name Michael Burtov.
My name is Dakota Decker.
Our company is
GeoOrbital.
We're from
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
We're seeking $500,000
for 5% of our company.
Sharks,
we give you the bicycle ‐‐
effectively unchanged
for over 100 years.
Now, maybe it's just me.
Maybe I watch
too much science fiction,
but I want
to take the bicycle
and introduce it
into the 21st century.
The GeoOrbital wheel is a step
into the future.
We made a way to turn almost
any bicycle electric
in under 60 seconds
with no tools.
So, what you see here is
a 100% normal bike,
exactly as you would buy
from a store,
completely unmodified.
All you do is take off
your regular front wheel,
put on the GeoOrbital wheel,
clip on the throttle,
and you're good
to go.
It takes under 60 seconds
to install...
and no tools.
Wow.
Now what you see here
is a powerful electric bike.
The motor will take you
about zero to 20 miles an hour
in under 10 seconds.
You can travel up to 20 miles
on a single charge
without even peddling.
You're going up a hill ‐‐
no sweat.
You've got 500 watts
of power available
at the press of a lever.
So, can I try it?
Absolutely.
You can. Yeah, yeah.
Here, let me ‐‐
I got another one
for you guys, too.
Okay, so,
what do I need to know?
Let me grab the helmet for you.
So, it's literally exactly like
you would ride any bicycle.
The pedals and brakes work
exactly the same.
Yeah.
The only difference is
this little button here.
Here, does somebody else
want to try?
Never wear a helmet
on television.
[ Chuckles ]
That's just ‐‐
That's a blackmail photo
for the rest of your life.
Oh, yeah!
That is very cool!
Oh, oh!
I'm gonna catch Kevin,
is what I'm gonna do.
Yeah, look at that!
Like riding a bike.
Yeah.
The blind
chasing the blind.
Oh, my God!
Where's the brake?!
Burtov:
You got to pedal backwards!
Decker: You got to pedal
backwards on that one!
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
Here we go!
‐Yeah, please.
‐Yeah.
Anybody else want to try?
It's fun.
It's like magic!
Are you at Kickstarter
and Indiegogo?
Burtov: We only actually
launched the company
about four months ago.
We raised $1.26 million
on Kickstarter.
Wow!
And after that,
we've been ‐‐
we've had a little over $200,000
on our website
directly through residual media
and things like that.
And are you shipping
or still prototype?
We're gonna be shipping
in like two months.
We ‐‐ Two months.
Greiner: I don't think
we know the price.
Corcoran: No, we don't.
‐Did we ever hear the price?
‐We skipped over that one, no.
What is the price?
It'll retail for $950.
Right now ‐‐
$950 for the wheel?
For the wheel. Correct.
For the wheel, and...
Isn't it cheaper to buy
an electric bike?
It depends on the bike.
But you can get an electric bike
for under $950.
You can.
You can get an electric bike
for almost $500,
but it's the quality of the bike
that you're getting.
That's not a problem for you?
These are ‐‐
We haven't seen that
a problem
with our ‐‐ with our
pre‐order customers.
Sacca: Is the market
opportunity for this
just the bikes
that are out there today
that don't have
electric yet?
We feel it's ‐‐
There ‐‐ There's a hurdle
to biking for people.
If I get anxious,
if I get on a bike,
regular bike,
I'll get tired.
I'm anxious
about going up hills.
I'll be anxious
about getting ‐‐
sweating on my way to work,
right?
You don't have to sell us on
the promise of electric bikes.
I own a couple of them.
We're going in a direction
where all bikes that are shipped
ultimately are going to have
an electric option in them.
Would you ever
make a bike?
That's what I'm trying
to ask you.
Uh, I want to ‐‐ I want to show
you something real fast.
We ‐‐ We don't make
any bikes currently.
We made
something different.
[ Laughter ]
That is a cool bike!
I love the banana seat.
What've you got here?
Burtov:
This is how it works.
You just sit on it,
and it's the same thing.
It looks...
‐I love that bike.
‐It's very tight‐turning.
You've got a nice,
tight turning radius.
There's is nothing ‐‐
you cannot do anything like this
with any other technology.
So, this is also
something we sell.
And this is
a full electric bike.
That's a cool bike.
It's extremely nimble.
it's extremely small.
You can put it in the trunk of
your car.
Well, this bike ‐‐
what's this bike cost?
You say you're selling them
for $950?
This is $200
in addition to the wheel.
Where are you prioritizing
your time?
On the new bike
or that wheel?
Oh, the bike is
a side note.
Oh, the bike is for fun.
To be honest,
that was the opposite
of the answer
I wanted to hear.
This is gonna be as fast
as last season's
Dallas Mavericks'
playoff‐highlight reel.
Sacca:
I believe that ‐‐
Can I just say,
that highlight reel you ‐‐
Oh, wait, you don't have a team.
You don't have any highlights
of anything, do you?
[ Laughing ]
Corcoran: Oh, my gosh.
That's literally
your only comeback?
My gosh.
Is that I don't
own a basketball team?
Oh, that was a zinger.
I‐I believe
in this space.
Electric bikes are here to stay.
There's no doubt about it.
I just really like
to invest
in the thing
that's forward‐looking,
not the thing
that's retrofitted
to the existing
technology.
If you had told me
you were moving on this bike,
that I think,
as goofy as it looks right now,
is really innovative,
that would have gotten me
more excited.
I think there is
a good short‐term opportunity
in retrofitting
existing bikes,
but I want to be betting
on the long‐term
electric‐native bikes.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Retrofitting current
to make it future is the future.
We're making electric vehicles
out of stuff
that's collecting dust
in your basement.
This is the future.
Cuban: One of the biggest
challenges,
having been
in multiple bike companies,
is sales
and distribution, right?
Inevitably,
there's an initial jump online.
You know,
you get that initial surge
that you're going through
right now.
But it's just such
a competitive environment.
It is just so hard
to compete to sell bikes
against the big‐box retailers,
the small shops,
and all the different
alternatives.
It's just not a ‐‐
a business I want to be in,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
But let me also add,
as far as how we grow, right?
So, we're direct
to consumer now.
In the next two years,
we want to do a lot more fleet.
Delivery, services,
police,
tour guides,
bike shares...
Well, so does everybody.
So does everybody.
Every motorized vehicle...
But we ‐‐
they don't need new bikes.
It's kind of ‐‐
It's a good point.
Burtov: Police have
their current bikes.
Very good point.
Bike shares have
their current bikes.
At $950 a unit,
even significantly discounted,
that's gonna be
a big hurdle to overcome.
To me, there's three rules
to a great product.
Is it something
that people need and want?
that solves a problem?
Which, clearly, it does.
Can it be made
at an affordable price?
You have number one.
You have number two.
Right now,
you don't have number three.
And for that reason,
sadly, I'm out.
Okay.
O'Leary: I live
in the back bay in Boston,
in a tiny brownstone
with a tiny elevator.
And that bike,
the little one, fits in it.
Great for elevators.
So, I'm gonna come over
and buy one,
but I think you need
another couple of iterations
to get the cost down.
I think it has to go
below $300.
Guys, I'm a buyer
of the small bike,
but not the company.
I'm out.
Okay.
You still have
one Shark left.
♪♪
I'm so intrigued
by this little bike.
I even named it already.
I'd call it the Bug.
The Bug?
It just looks like a bug to me,
you know?
[ Laughs ]
Um, I think it's gonna be hard
to sell this.
I think the price
is too high.
I'd probably just buy myself
an electric bike,
'cause I can't picture myself
swapping.
And I think I'm not gonna be
alone in that regard.
So, I'm gonna join Kevin
and buy one, too.
But I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
Burtov: Yeah,
we appreciate your time.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck with everything.
♪♪
Burtov:
Although we didn't strike a deal
with the Sharks today,
this is definitely not the end
of GeoOrbital.
We're just
getting rolling.
[ Laughs ]
That's right.
♪♪
My name is Jeff McNeil,
and I'm from
Newton, Massachusetts.
I live here with my wife,
Stephanie, and my five kids.
My background is in design.
I spent nine years
running my own
custom software design company.
I eventually
lost my passion for it,
and I wanted to get back
to my roots.
‐All right, school's open.
‐You guys have a great day.
‐Love you, guys.
‐Bye!
Love you. Bye, babes.
Hey, I don't get
a hug anymore?
With this many kids,
there's lots of big moments
and lots
of little moments, too,
but never enough time
to keep track of it all.
I decided to use my background
in technology
to solve this problem
for ourselves
and introduce it
to parents everywhere.
Within two days
of having the idea,
I had written up a spec,
I had two developers
working on it,
and we knew that
we had a million‐dollar idea.
Okay, line up,
find your letter.
I'm nervous that I've put it all
on the line for this business.
I've got five mouths to feed,
five kids to clothe,
five kids
to put through college.
This is real.
With the Sharks' help,
I know that I can get my product
out to parents everywhere
so that they can treasure
their kids' special memories
forever.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jeff McNeil.
And I'm here today
from Newton, Massachusetts,
seeking $350,000
in exchange for 10% equity.
With my company, Qeepsake,
you'll never miss a memory.
Every parent
has one of these, right?
A baby book.
It's supposed to house
all your child's important
milestones, firsts,
and memorable moments.
But most of these books,
they look just like this ‐‐
empty.
You started filling it out,
but you got busy.
So before you know it,
you can't go back
and recall the details
of when your son or daughter
learned to take
their first steps
or to ride a two‐wheeler.
As parents,
we're busier than ever,
and this thing ‐‐ it doesn't fit
into our lifestyle.
What if saving memories
and milestones
were as easy
as sending a text message?
Meet Qeepsake.
I'm a father
of five myself,
so I have tons of memories.
Five!
Let me save one about
my daughter Annabel right now.
I'll show you how easy this is,
Sharks.
So, Qeepsake has just texted me
an insightful question
about Annabel,
and all I have to do
is text back, and that's it.
I have a new memory stored
in the Qeepsake journal
for Annabel.
Oh, earlier today,
my son Owen ‐‐
he lost
his second front tooth,
and I want to save that
to Qeepsake.
So I write a text...
and I attach a photo,
and I'm done.
On the website,
I can see all my entries ‐‐
I can fix
the inevitable typos.
When you're ready,
you can order
the gorgeous Qeepsake book.
By investing in Qeepsake,
you're backing the best team
to become the leader
in this huge, untapped market.
Jeff, do you have
an example of the book?
Can we see samples?
Sure.
So, these are samples
of my own book
for my daughter, Annabel.
Here you go.
Awesome. Thanks.
Five?!
Five.
Five kids!
It's not five times
as hard as one.
[ Laughs ]
What are their ages?
Oldest is 8,
youngest is 1.
Oh, goodness.
Wow.
You've been
in the weeds forever.
No wonder
you look exhausted.
I have an amazing wife.
So...there's not a lot
on each page.
Do people customize it
to put as much as they want
on a page?
So, the book is
an auxiliary product for us.
That book is
effectively a prototype.
I'm gonna shock you
by saying
we've sold a total
of four books.
Four?
We ‐‐ We think
there's a demand for books,
but it's not right now.
You know, this would've been
really great to have
when Barbara was a baby,
but they didn't have
‐any film or photography then.
‐[ Laughs ]
I might be able to do something
about that, Sharks.
Let me make this
more real for you.
Oh!
Corcoran: Oh, come on!
Aww!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Boy, is she cute!
‐Bar!
You can tell she's brilliant
just looking at her.
‐[ Chuckling ] Whoa!
‐Who's that?
Sacca: Wait.
O'Leary:
That's a good‐looking guy.
That's you?
Greiner: Kevin!
Absolutely.
‐[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
‐Kevin!
Sacca: Was that a wig?
Cuban: Kevin!
What a cutie.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, no.
‐Who's that?
It's me, Barb.
That's what's up right there,
baby!
[ Laughter ]
‐That is a stud in the making!
‐That's nasty.
Sacca: Math club.
You never got smooshed
into a locker,
did you, Mark?
Yikes!
Corcoran:
Is that the cowboy?
Oh yeah, it is.
‐All carbs, all the time.
‐All carbs?
So, how much do I pay
for the app?
The business model is
on subscription,
and it's not an app.
It's a service that works
over text message.
Okay, what's
the subscription fee?
Cuban:
So, explain to us ‐‐
explain to us
your membership options
and the cost for each.
Sure, so the...
average plan price is $40.
It goes up to $95.
Per annum.
Per year.
Right, per annum.
And we have over 40,000
activated users.
So, let me give you
a shocking number.
We're converting 16%
of our user base
to a paid subscription.
That's a high
conversion rate.
Why don't I just use Note,
attach a picture...
Right, or why don't you just use
Facebook or Instagram?
Sure.
You have a fair concern.
This is stuff that you ‐‐
for Facebook or Instagram,
it doesn't belong there.
It's ‐‐ It's over‐sharing.
It's personal.
The real innovation is that
we're helping people
at prompting questions.
And Note doesn't know
how old your kids are.
Note doesn't work with you
to go, "Hey"...
Is ‐‐ Is there any intelligence
to the questions,
or is it a standard list
that you send to everybody?
There's hundreds and hundreds
of Qeepsake questions.
They're all age‐informed.
But, Jeff, how do you support
your family?
Great ‐‐ Great question ‐‐
So, first and foremost,
we're actually making money
with Qeepsake.
I'm now taking a salary.
Qeepsake has made over $250,000
in revenue in four months.
‐Wow, that surprises me.
‐That's impressive.
Jeff, you're one of these guys
who gets better as you talk.
But I like to make a difference
in my entrepreneurs.
I'm not sure how I could
help you on this.
So I'm out.
Jeff, when you first
walked in here,
you were boring me
to death.
I was already out.
But the more you talked,
the more interested I got.
I have a whole slew
of companies
that already have
your customers ‐‐
Lovepop, Honeyfund,
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
All of these have
massive databases
of parents with kids.
So, I'm gonna make you
an offer, okay?
I'll do $350,000 for 20%.
Cuban: Jeff,
I'll clear the deck some.
Look,
I think it's a great product.
My ‐‐ My only issue
with it is,
the minute you get
to a certain level
and you get
a lot of attention,
somebody's going to compete,
right?
Like you said,
there's no barriers to entry.
And that's gonna be the
challenge for you.
I am worried about that, Jeff,
I really am.
There's worries
in every business.
No, of course, yeah.
Every single business
has concerns.
There is.
And, look,
I‐I just don't see
it ‐‐ It's a business
I want to be in.
Um, so for those reasons,
I'm out.
I appreciate the feedback.
Thanks.
Problem is,
I'm not the right partner
to escalate this very rapidly
for you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
O'Leary:
You know what I'm thinking?
If you're not
taking my deal,
you're hoping that somebody
will do it for less equity.
The risk you've got is,
as the Sharks drop out,
it makes me greedier.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Jeff has an offer on the table
from Kevin
for his text‐based
online journal company,
Qeepsake.
But his offer may get worse
now that all but one other Shark
has dropped out.
O'Leary:
The risk you've got is,
as the Sharks drop out,
it makes me greedier.
You don't do a deal
with somebody
just to get access
to their mailing list.
Kevin's old enough that
he needs memory aids,
and I really think this product
would be great for him.
Ask him a question today ‐‐
That makes me unhappier!
[ Laughs ]
So, I don't like your deal,
and here's why.
20% doesn't leave enough
for future rounds.
You need to have me
and the other founders
thinking like owners
the whole time.
I'm gonna counter.
So, I came in
with $350,000 for 10%.
I'm gonna move the equity up
to 12%.
Look, let me tell you,
I think you're solving
a real problem,
and you're going about it
the right way.
Prompt‐based daily questioning
is a great way
to get somebody
to create content.
I was frustrated to hear you
push back on Kevin's offer,
because that was the same offer
I was gonna make you.
And I know I bring more
to the table
for an app like this
than Kevin ever could.
Not a chance in hell.
Dude, what are ‐‐
just mailing your e‐mailing list
doesn't actually bring
everything that comes
with working with somebody
to build a product,
to build a strategy.
If you already have a customer,
if you have actually
got a parent,
and they're buying a service
already,
that's a much higher probability
of a sale.
Yeah.
I'm ‐‐ I'm really proud
of your 10,000 buyers
over there.
Like, if I'm getting involved
in something,
we're gonna make it big,
and we're going to
millions and millions.
But in order to make this
compelling for me,
I would need to own the 20%
of the company.
That's what it would take
to get me excited
and working on
really developing this product.
That's what I do for a living,
is make products better.
And so, my offer is
the $350,000 for the 20%.
Appreciate the offer.
I'm gonna counter back ‐‐
$350,000, 14%.
So first of all,
I'm deeply flattered
that you gave me a better price
than Mr. Wonderful
right out of the gate.
You gave him 2% better
than Kevin.
I'm gonna sleep well tonight
just knowing that.
Kevin, are you staying in?
Because it's ‐‐
I'm in pain now,
waiting for you
to make your decision,
I'll make it easy
for you ‐‐
I'm out.
Are you going down,
Chris?
Now, I...
Uh...
Jeff: What's ‐‐ So, the concern
is there's too much work.
It's too risky
on the competitive landscape.
I don't know what
the competitive landscape is,
and you haven't convinced me
that it's clear.
Get me comfortable
that there's
nobody else out there
who's gonna come after you.
So I can't guarantee there's
nobody going after the space,
but I can guarantee that nobody
pops up on our radar
with this level
of traction.
Why do you win?
We win because we've done this
time and time again.
The market is there.
Everybody is there.
They're waiting
for the solution.
They don't know about it.
I want to work with you.
I can't do the 20% because it ‐‐
it's too much dilution.
The valuation is
too low for us.
Well, you're sucking up
very well, I have to admit.
The question is,
will it save you any equity?
It's genuine.
Are you willing
to do it for less, Chris?
That's all.
You nailed that response,
but you still didn't
get me there.
I like your approach.
I think I could help you
make it a lot better.
But I got to dig in
at 20%.
That's what makes it
meaningful for me.
Under any circumstance,
you're not doing 20%?
I would 20% for more money.
[ Laughs ]
I came in here with
a 3.15 pre‐money valuation.
I think it's very fair.
At a certain point,
you just have to make
the decision.
Corcoran: So,
what's your decision?
So, I will respectfully decline
the offer.
I appreciate the feedback
and the consideration.
Congrats, Jeff.
Thank you.
O'Leary: You know, he wasn't
gonna do a deal for 20%.
That's it.
It's that simple.
Yep.
I could've got him
another 200,000 users, easily.
He's a bozo.
He didn't think that through.
I honestly feel like
this was the best opportunity
that's ever stood
in front of the Sharks,
and they will sincerely regret
not getting a piece of it.
♪♪